hey everyone first of all thank you so
much for being here with me through this
Evolution on my podcast it is truly an
honor and I've had so many incredible
conversations that I'm thankful to have
been able to share with you all this
episode is going to be a little
different I've decided to round out
these episodes I've shared with you with
an end of season highlights and full
transparency here I originally was not
planning on doing seasons for this
podcast I envisioned uploading an
episode once every two weeks
indefinitely but since giving birth to
my fifth child I have found it
incredibly difficult to keep up with my
NeverEnding to-do list while also
maintaining balance with my family so I
often feel overwhelmed by the number of
tasks I need to complete for my business
and that doesn't even include regular
daily chores and quality time with my
kids let alone a little sprinkled
self-care for myself thrown in here and
there so I realize something's got to
give and I need to be more intentional
with balance in my life and they are
little for only so long and maintaining
the balance of raising my children well
earning an income for my family and
following my passions at the same time
is a challenge for sure and for a little
Clarity I don't have a large team
editing and curating and completing many
tasks for me I create and edit the
majority of my projects myself partly
because I can be a bit of a control
freak and have difficulty handing off my
work to someone else to create my vision
and the other part being the difficulty
it can be to find experienced people in
this podcast field in person on this
little island we live on so I've decided
instead of uploading an episode episode
once every two weeks I'll be sharing a
bulk of 10 to 12 episodes per season and
then taking a break to rebuild up my
episodes in a time frame that works for
me which will create a little more
flexibility in my life and also give me
the time and space to really create all
the best episodes I've been dying to
create I want to do more debate episodes
this next season and I'm really going to
take my time with them so I hope you're
on board with me and for this episode I
wanted to share some highlights of my
favorite conversations I've had so far
on the podcast I've learned so much from
these thought leaders and I'm inspired
by their messages and stories and I feel
humbled to have gotten a chance to sit
with them and ask those burning
questions I wrestle with the first one
is from an episode that was a bit
underrated but was actually one of my
favorites I had the honor of sitting
down with Dominic Thompson a former drug
dealer turned Healthcare Executive then
after incarceration an activist and
social impact entrepreneur this episode
is on issues in the prison system food
insecurity and marginalized communities
vegan masculinity and health care versus
sickcare our conversation was compelling
definitely one of my favorite episodes
thus far and there's a particular
section of our conversation where we
went back and forth on universal
healthcare that I loved take a listen
these Health Systems and these payers
are making money off of sick people so
when you go to Universal he I'm actually
Pro universal healthcare when you go to
universal healthcare you you eliminate
that whole human psych py psyche of
wanting to cut corners and make money
into monetize off of sick people we
should not be monetizing off of anyone
sick Healthcare is definitely a human
right to me and if anything that we seen
in this pandemic is the fact that we all
should have access to Quality Healthcare
because it's going to make a better and
healthy Community I agree with you that
we should all have access to it it's
more about like is this the answer but I
guess when I go back to things like
universal healthcare I look at the
healthcare that we have in America and
compare it to other countries and the
healthcare they have when it's
government run mhm and what it's not
like necessarily driven as much by
something like if you're just going to
say a blanket St like profit I feel like
there's more layers to that but when you
look at America almost universally
people are flocking here to get our
healthare than the other way around like
you're not going to find someone from
Texas going to Canada for healthcare
because we have such a free market
system like there's a there's a reason
why America has like some of the biggest
and most amazing inventions and
technological advances it's because the
reward is so great and when you take
away the reward
of like making such a big risk doing
such a big risk to like invent something
like life-saving technological um
equipment for surgeries or a drug that
is life-saving right things like that if
you take away the reward being so great
and it all just kind of like it's not
about profit then you lower the quality
like I look at personal things when
they're like government run I look at
like the DMV and the US Post Office and
the quality of service that you get when
it's government run versus something
like up that's privately run and they're
like look I want people to choose UPS
because I'm all about business and I'm
about trying to bring provide the best
product and service and then there's
like incentive it's like a natural
desire to like do your best when it
comes to things like that so that's kind
of my thoughts but I I think a lot of
people fail to realize because you if
you do go with a Universal Health Care
model you don't eliminate the free
market the free market is still develop
people in Canada still have the option
to go to elect if they don't want to
wait on their surgery or whatever
they're going through because we do live
in a society where all humans especially
in the western region are number one Le
impatient people want what they want
right now you know and that's the
problem that's people are like oh I need
to have a surgery look surgeries are
important but there are definitely some
some things that can wait a week or a
couple of days where you're not a
priority but people want they expect
that right away and that's the some of
the uh talking points of people that are
opposed to
ping out there and you're not going to
eliminate the free market if you have
the money to go pay a surgeon sooner
than later to have whatever you need to
have done or even to get access to more
medicine quicker than waiting 24 to 48
hours I kind of blame the whole business
model of Amazon people when they click
on that button yeah they expect the same
day to get service or even restaurant
fast food casual everything people are
just we're we live in a society where
people have no patience no patience and
it and it and it's spilling over in
other in Industries and communities
including Healthcare so free market is
not going to be eliminated still going
to be there but then you have universal
healthcare and it's just going to make a
more better Community because that
little boy or girl that might have some
type of virus like you know whatever
whether are we talking Co or something
new in the future Co 800 I don't know
and and but when you have so they may
have a different family background where
their mom and dad May don't have a h uh
uh HMO you know they may have a PO or
or or or a free market or selfcare I
mean self-insured where they may don't
have access to the same Quality Health
System but you integrate that in that
same community that school system that
kid can have an impact whatever they're
carrying on your kid but when you have
quality universal healthcare everyone's
going to be protected in some type of um
umbrella where you don't have to really
worry about little things like that so
it the model works but the free market
still would be there so do you think
that it should should be like um raising
taxes to cover healthcare for all but
then keep health care and a lot of um
practices within Healthcare privatized
not necessarily government run but it's
free for everyone but it's not
necessarily free like it's not free
because someone's paying for it well
well let's be honest the whole tax code
and the tax issue in general was
probably the first thing that left or
right should have dismantled and and
presented itself before that overhaul of
healthcare years ago we we had to really
address that but Al be very transparent
about like I said um this digital
currency this borrowing money from here
and there yeah there's a lot involved
with taxes and that's our money as as
you US citizens but we do have resources
more than we know it you know and and we
can fund these things or even reallocate
to a different part yeah um that instead
of a very bloated bloated bloated super
bloated military um Yes actually I was
going to bring that up because that's I
agree with you there's one factor that
Mak we don't need new f-16s every
year or new tanks every year so much of
our tax dollars gets allocated towards
military funding and I don't I I
definitely don't consider myself an
expert to know how much money we should
be allocating towards it the biggest it
is the biggest in the world because
we're kind of we kind of act like the
police of the world we have our military
infiltrated everywhere in the world
so country yeah so I'm with you if we're
going to do more things like making it
uh more affordable and available like
more types of um types of services
available towards all because right now
you have the ability if you have
emergency care you're not like you're
not going to be denied service no matter
who you are but let's talk about things
like surgeries and things like that
there's a few things I want to say one
like I think it's hard for us to compare
to like another country that it works
for because they don't spend so much
money on the military so I'm with you if
we're going to go that way let's at
least I mean because our cuz our
military is protecting them anyway so
yeah I know so they don't have to spend
the money don't have a big military
America's going for us over here right
but we have to spend the money
are just pull out because there's a lot
of people haer's a lot of threats there
so there's not about Canada I'm not
talking about Canada but you know what
I'm saying like we have we're
infiltrated a lot of places brother to
protect yeah so I I understand that
aspect but that's why it's hard for us
to just compare to another country that
it works for so there's some people in
Canada we're just using Canada as an
example who really likes their
Healthcare and then there's some people
who really hate it cuz I you know I've
definitely spoken to people who are like
takes two or 3 months to get a surgery
that really need whereas in America you
can just go and get it right away and
part of that or it might be that surgeon
part of that not to interrupt you I'm
sorry but part of that too cuz I talked
to those same people it's because they
have a special doctor they want to go to
it's just a lot you got to consider
those factors yeah there's always layers
and factors and I feel like this is such
a complex topic it be like a whole
episod but it's really fun I actually
find it so fascinating CU there's so
many details that's hard to understand
and I want to unpack it and really
understand it cuz there's layers to it
right but I forget what was I saying I
was um basically just mentioning that
like it comes at a cost if if if we're
all paying higher taxes to be able to do
this Universal um covering Healthcare
and the government decides what you can
pay for or not that's when you start
having delays in things because they
have to decide what you can who can get
it how many times a month how many
patients can they take per thing and
because we are already like so in debt
and because another the hugest factor is
that we're the most unhealthy Nation we
have the most obesity the most diabetes
the most heart disease the most
prescription jug use by far like I was
actually looking at the stats we the
amount of Americans that take
prescription drugs um regularly it's
significantly higher than any other
nation and so when you factor all that
in I think it's like the idea is nice
but I'm just not sure if that's
necessarily the first thing we should do
you know I'm not like against it I'm not
like definitely not I'm more just like I
think there's other things like sub
subsidizing healthy food like you said
preventative care that I think is like
far definitely where we should start
first yeah for sure I mean yeah I mean
cuz you you're not you're just putting a
Band-Aid even if you have a healthare
you just put in a Band-Aid a bigger
problem where we have to get to the root
of the problem which is eat healthier
yes and we have such a crippled Health
Care System it's total sick care and
it's just like we rely on it so much so
so much so many people having to go all
the time and if we could prevent that we
also are one of those Nations that very
rarely do any kind of natural
alternatives you go to a reg Hospital
holistically it's like this is it drug
surgy drug surgery drug surg other
countries aren't like that so maybe but
how would you what would you think would
be a good way to shift that like
policy-wise well policy-wise is we
probably need to be rewarding more uh
medical students to go more into
holistic care one one thing is what I've
been seeing a lot though there are a lot
more holistic providers coming out and
and of coming these these met students
are practicing and opening up a more
holistic approach and and but you're
right we are driven off a A drugs and
and food is is really medicine over what
should be prescribed as a drug over
medicine and don't get me wrong um
Western medicine and modern medicine in
general has definitely saved a lot of
lives and has been very influential in
um the human race thriving in different
capacities uh but we do and we should
always look at more holistically the the
approach of holistic medicine before any
thing that we are condition to think in
black and white that we learned in med
school just take this pill uh for
whatever symptom that you're
experiencing that this might not even be
a symptom that just probably needs to
tweaking in your diet next we have the
most viral episode I've shared on this
podcast so far which has over half a
million views on YouTube and Counting a
pro-life versus pro-choice debate that I
hosted between lla Rose and Brenda
Davies Layla is a pro-choice activist
and founder and president of live action
the largest pro-life nonprofit across
the globe Brenda is a writer podcaster
and pro-choice Christian who believes
that forced birth is immoral this was a
fire conversation that was over 3 hours
long yet people could not turn the
episode off because it was so compelling
it was hard to highlight a section from
this episode because the entire thing is
truly a must listen but here's a piece
where they go back and forth on if human
life in the womb is worth protecting
or if other problems in our world should
be addressed instead to make this Earth
more habitable to human life so mothers
are more likely to choose to keep their
pregnancies on their own if you've been
wanting to work on your fitness journey
but don't know where to begin or you
feel a bit lost or unmotivated then
listen up co-pilot has been the best way
for me to reach my fitness goals because
I have somebody holding my hand and
guiding me I've reached new goals that I
never did before and I feel so good in
my body so co-pilot is an affordable
Fitness coach app that provides
personalized workouts tailored to your
goals and available equipment you get
accountability and support from a real
person with the flexibility to work out
on your own schedule first you get
paired with a fitness and health coach
and have an onboarding call with them
you share with them your personal
fitness goals and your favorite ways to
work out and then your coach will create
a customized workout plan just for you
they utilize whatever equipment you have
available to you whether that's at home
or the gym and then you stay connected
with your coach and get feedback to
tweak your workouts according to your
needs I love my expert coach she
motivates me and I get notifications and
reminders on my phone encouraging to get
a workout in and it's really keeping me
on track I'm using heavier weights than
when I started and I'm able to do
exercises a lot easier that used to be
difficult for me I love that I never
have to think about what to do when it
comes to Fitness because it's all
planned out for me and also clients can
switch coaches anytime in the app if
they don't think their coach is the
right fit for them over 75% of co-pilot
clients continue to work out after 100
days which means co-pilot clients are
nine times more successful at sticking
to their goals so click my co-pilot Link
in the show notes to get 14 days free
with your own person trainer the
starting point in my book and the reason
that I'm working to educate every day
about what abortion actually is connect
women to the resources that are out
there is that we cannot have a culture
of life really people flourish if we
literally in our communities have
centers set up where people are killing
pre-born children and and that's that
that is a culture of death by definition
there's so many other cultures of death
in our society though that make that a
necessity for I agree with you there's a
lot of other I agree with you I'm going
to push back a little on the necessity
word because I think women are a lot
more uh capable than we give them credit
for a lot of the time and there's a lot
more resources that do exist I think
fear is a big part of a lot of abortions
fear of the future um fear of the
repercussions and so I think part of it
those fears are legitimate I I I'm not
speaking your child is going into an
Abus of foster care system like that
fear is legitimate it's based in a a
reality it's based in a fact if you are
a black woman in Louisiana being forced
to give birth and one of that they have
the number one highest maternal death
rate in our nation and you think
abortion is helping wom more women give
birth health healthfully I mean that it
doesn't make sense I I think that if you
are hypothetically a black I mean I
don't doesn't improve maternal mortality
rates for for black women yes but I'm
talking about the necess oftion or this
fear like you can't minimize or say that
people are just in fear I know you're
I'm not trying to imply you're
minimizing anything but I'm saying to
just say well people are resilient and
they can actually do better when I have
a society around me a nation and a party
that claims to be pro-life but does so
many things that actually result in the
opposite like these are not just fears
these are valid valid concerns that are
happening every single day the highest
maternal death rates in this country
happen to be in states that are wanting
to force birth Louisiana Texas there's
many others Jersey they're not all even
just pro-life so so-called States and we
are not even focusing on a maternal
death rate problem or the maternal death
rate of black women so it's
not that abortion has to be a necessity
and I can understand why you push back
on that however if you already have
children which is the majority of people
who seek out abortions and you're
worried about poverty which is valid and
you're seeing your children not be able
to eat and seeing all these systemic
problems your kids are getting shot in
school these are not just fears these
are valid concerns that cause people to
say you know what I don't want to bring
a baby into this inhospitable place
where I might
die there it's going to take our entire
nation our Unity um to solve that and
that's why I got so frustrated and I
still feel that frustration inside of me
on what I'm calling the mouse wheel
because our aligning and deciding we
agree when life begins will not also
change my stance on what needs to happen
and that abortion needs to be accessible
until we can make sure those freaking
women aren't dying out there and I I
think we're in agreement that there is a
death culture in our country a culture
that is often very inhabitable to human
flourishing and it's all Hands-On deck
it's in how we treat each other it's in
how we treat our own families that
were're given or we're born into or
chosen families it's in you know the
communities we're part of and how we're
helping our neighbors there's a lot
there to unpack but how I I I can't it
it it is um I think impossible to
achieve I think the society you're
dreaming of and I agree I I'm United
with you and a society that's open to
human life flourishing human beings can
flourish while permitting the violent
Act of abortion against our youngest and
most vulnerable members and that's why
I'm here I'm here to say I can't give
you that point to say oh it's okay to
just kill them in the womb as long as
they're 20 weeks not 21 weeks and then
we're going to go out and make life
better for everybody else I we can't
those two things can't hold together we
need to say all life is precious and set
the tone right from the beginning and
act on that go in reverse because until
this place is hospitable like every
place that prioritizes its citizens
prioritizes comprehensive sexed from 5
years old prioritizes access to birth
control prioritizes not killing at
citizens to gunfire the Myriad of things
prioritizes maternal health and making
sure women don't die in birth the
Nations that do that have lower rates of
abortion than we do in this country
because I why why wouldn't you then like
then you would actually have to have
another reason then you would jump to
another thing like to me the true
tragedy is that many people go into
those abortion clinics and they are
there out of a necessity that is not
just perceived it is valid and real and
we are not focusing on how to make it
hospitable for them next up is the
episode on problems with our school
system and why the school system is
failing our youth with Matt budro a
former public and private school teacher
and administrator Matt is a provocative
thought leader in the realm of Education
here's a slice of that riveting
conversation I am on the side of good
human beings who are teachers and
administrators in our modern system and
when I say modern system I don't just
mean Public Schools I also mean private
schools cuz private schools are modeled
very much after the the public school
system if you're a good human in those
systems I am on your side I love you I
thank you I appreciate you I want
nothing but the best for you I think you
need to be there because those systems
aren't going away and there are some
young people the reality is you're going
to be the best human beings they're
going to meet because they go home and
the humans that are raising them are are
not quite as as uh intentional and not
quite as loving right so I want those
people there my beef is is always with
the system itself so you asked how is
that different well the difference
is the system that we utilize is a
system of schooling schooling and
education aren't the same if education
is for sovereignty and drawing out that
unique ability and being able to
scaffold a life that you want to live
well it's the antithesis because
schooling says everybody do the same
thing at the same time in this very
narrow uh scheme of Academia that
doesn't really necessarily transfer over
to anything else in life it's not a
system that is easily transferable and I
always tell people it's like you know
you go for 12 years every day to learn
how to play checkers and then all of a
sudden you graduate and everybody's like
okay cool here's your basketball go
shoot a three-pointer and you're like
wait I've been playing checkers for 12
years right it's well like yeah but
they're both games okay but they're very
different games that require very
different skill sets and they have very
different rules so being good at school
and and we know this being good at
school does not necessarily mean you're
good at life some people are good at
school and then they go out and they
crush it but I would say it's in spite
of not because of because you and I both
know people that didn't do well in
school but they're phenomenally
successful they're wildly happy they're
very intentional about their life we
also know people who got the straight
days and are miserable and you know the
success hasn't transferred over right so
that's my problem with this it's
actually the antithesis of what
education should be first of all I'm so
glad that you brought up teachers and
affirming the good teachers the good
people that are in our education system
because I think a lot of times people
hear criticism of the education system
and assume it that means that there's
criticism of just all the teachers
lumping everyone together when really
that's not what you're talking about so
yeah so I'm so glad you brought that up
at the beginning of this conversation
and then secondly when you're talking
about our education system and the
difference between what you think
education should be versus what our
modern system is um a lot of times it
feels like education is meant to be for
how to get a job not how to be
successful in life and when you say
success in life some people think well
that means when you get a good job
that's success in life but success in
life is um could mean a lot of different
things and not just to that so it's a
personal question right success for me
looks very different than success for
you because we're different people
there's some things that cross over for
sure and if you ask parents and I've had
the opportunity and again I I've been a
public school teacher I've been a public
school administrator I've been a private
school teacher a private school
administrator I worked at Stanford I've
worked with universities all over the
world I know the game inside now and if
you talk to parents and you say hey what
do you want for your young Heroes when
they get older there is a a somewhat of
a baseline answer right but the Baseline
answer is I want them to be happy I want
them to be healthy I want them to be
productive I want them to have good
relationships you know I want them to be
somewhat Sovereign I want them to spend
every day excited I want those are the
Baseline answers nobody says I want them
to be wildly proficient at Algebra 2
when they're you know that's never the
answer right so those are the baselines
so when you understand that that's the
Baseline you go crap well how do you
make sure that you have that for every
person it's a really tough thing to say
well there's a standardized process when
life is anything but standard your you
know our backgrounds are anything but
standard right it's almost impossible to
really make that to make that happen
okay guys I'll be the first to admit
that I love pretty things so if I find a
product that nourishes me and looks
beautiful on the kitchen counter I am
all in anema Moody herbals does just
that they carry organic wildcrafted and
ethically grown Botanicals in the most
beautiful packaging from Elderberry
syrup and adaptogenic mushrooms to
spirulina chocolate protein teas and
collagen booster powders every vibrant
and medically potent remedy is packaged
in eco-friendly packaging of recyclable
glass or biodegradable bags it was
founded by Costa Rican herbalist Adriana
aalis who uses over 200 different
sustainably grown herbs from around the
world to create intentional products
that contain zero fillers binders or
flow agents everything is made in the US
with certified organic wildcrafted and
sustainably harvested plants and herbs
and a vegan and gluten-free kitchen I
love their High potency Elderberry syrup
which is double extracted it's
adaptogenic antiviral organic and
wildcrafted perfect for supporting
healthy immune function so use my code
ellen2 for 20% off just click the link
in my show notes to get this deal from
an amazing company that supports Fair
Trade Practices Beyond organic farming
education and small farmers to create
remedies that benefit people from all
walks of life the most damaging part of
a conveyor school system is that we are
teaching the young people they are not
to be
trusted can you elaborate on that like
explain it a little bit more you bet you
are only allowed to uh really speak to
for the majority of the day people of
your own dat of manufacturer right like
if I'm six I'm only around other
six-year-olds so true I can right if I'm
12 I hang out with 12-year-olds I
automatically get to look down on the
youngers I automatically have to rever
the olders
but then I'm going to stand in my
straight line I'm going to raise my hand
and ask permission for anything and
everything for years on end including
I'm going to ask another human being
even though I'm 18 if I can go to the
bathroom that human being might go no
and I go okay right I'm learning to be
blindly obedient to anybody who claims
to be in Authority I am this is your
assignment this is what you're going to
do you're if you obey well I'll give you
an a if you go outside the box on this
you're not going to get the the
arbitrary letter grade that I'm going to
give you okay sounds good I'm working on
it ding Bell Rings move on to the next
part of the conveyor belt whether you're
enjoying what you're doing or not it
doesn't matter right it's this
Industrial Revolution model based on
authoritarianism that builds that
mindset into the young
Heroes you leave there going I don't
know anything about me but I know how to
obey I know how to follow directions
tell me what to somebody tell me what to
do next and we wonder why when the
government or whoever claims to be
Authority goes look this is what you're
going to do and this is when you're
going to do it people go yep you got it
sure whatever you say Alisa
silverstone's light-heartedness and
enthusiasm for all things natural and
respectful parenting are some of my
favorite things about her she is open
and down toe and I'm thankful to know
her this episode landed Alicia in hot
water for a few days across the news
because of her willingness to share
openly about her connected relationship
with her son it started with one online
article about how Alicia still sleeps in
the same bed with her 11-year-old son
bear that quickly spread to Good Morning
America Fox News Yahoo ABC News Daily
wire and even the view so Alysia
Silverstone has always been outspoken
about her unique style of parenting from
poty training her son without diapers to
pre- chewing his food for him when he
was younger and she said on the Ellen
Fisher podcast that she's not a shamed
at her approach to Motherhood take a
look I'm a natural mama and I'm a loving
mama and I believe in love and I believe
in nature and our society is scared of
Nature and scared of love bear and I
still sleep together wow yes so that's
another thing like all the all the stat
I'll be in trouble for saying that but I
don't really
care I don't know any 11-year-old that
wants to sleep with me and while it was
pretty cool to hear whoopy Goldberg say
my name cuz guys I loved the Sister Act
growing up and Alis and I definitely
laughed about my fan girl moment it's a
shame how quickly the media can run with
something so innocent and turn it into
negativity these articles left readers
who easily jump on the bandwagon of
whatever the news is hyped up about for
that particular hour to make assumptions
about her and that was a shame you go
Alicia keep being you and thanks for
coming on my podcast take a listen to
the clip that caused a stir in the news
you have since bear was little have a
lot of alternative ways of raising him
that maybe the broader Society kind of
looked at like what are you doing and I
even have seen like an article it's like
all the things that Alicia Silverstone
did does that are are terrible that are
so anti like not status quo so maybe we
can get into a little bit of those like
you co-slept and things like that yeah I
just do what's I'm a natural mama and
I'm a loving mama and I believe in love
and I believe in nature and and our
society is scared of Nature and scared
of love and so that right there that's
the whole podcast I think that's it I
mean they they are they react as if they
it's okay with women to be naked on the
beach I don't mean naked like on a naked
beach I mean with a string up their bum
as a bathing suit and like no bathing
suit that's okay but a woman can't
breastfeed that is very interesting and
I'm just like what why is it okay for
women to be sexualized on in on a beach
or in the in our movies or whatever
andard or videos like just yeah but we
can't gently feed our children with the
thing that was made to feed them like
what is wrong with you and he says I
know that is very weird so that's you
know one thing then there's all these
other cultures and all these other
people that do it the things I'm doing
I'm not
inventing I didn't invent any of it I
would love to take credit for all of it
but it's not me for unfort Ely it's just
me following nature yeah and yeah
sleeping with your children I mean if
you were in a for if you were in a in in
any kind of um wild setting where
there're animals if you put your baby
over there your baby's going to get
eaten so it's not ideal for the baby to
be over there that's how I thought too
like back when I was get first like
going to have Elvis like the topic of Co
sleeping or crib and everything like
that I'm like but if I was like sleeping
outside in a tent I wouldn't put him in
a separate tent no like no way no
and their little bodies are designed to
have milk every they they're they need
that milk every 2 hours when they're
building up into you know their baby
their bellies are to so tiny and it
actually makes you sleep so much better
I remember when I first had bear I would
get up to go breastfeed him he was still
in bed with me but I would get up I
don't know why I just I was a new mom so
get up and then one of my friends said
why are you doing that just roll over
yeah and I was like oh yeah oh yeah but
my boobs aren't quite big enough I don't
think I had the big the big ones that
could kind of get in there as well but I
start I I started and it it does save a
lot and then I would find that you'd be
asleep you'd be on one side and then you
wake up and you're like how' he get on
that side because I didn't you know but
um but I just think it's delicious I
think being a mom is the most precious
most like unbelievable experience in
this world and it's not for everyone and
you know anybody who doesn't want to do
it shouldn't do it but for
me I just It's So Divine it's and I
wanted to savor every moment of his life
and that's why I didn't I wanted to have
more but then my my relationship got
messed up and then it was not a great
time to bring one in but I didn't want
to have one right away because I was so
in love with my bear I wanted to every
squeeze every little moment out of him
so it wasn't until he was like three
that I was ready to make another baby
and then I didn't have partner
so so that's why I don't have four
babies but I would I I wouldn't probably
want four babies but I would definitely
want two or three so but being I would
not be you Ellen no no I don't think I
could do that um but maybe maybe you're
lot you started a lot younger than I did
I just can't I'm way older than you no
you don't seem older well I'm way older
than you so you started younger um if I
had started younger I probably would be
you I knew that when I was little I knew
I had to wait because I thought if I
start I won't stop and um but my point
is that nurturing this little monkey and
having him you know I just wanted to do
what was healthiest for him at every
turn and so every choice I make is
either buil built on instinct or deep
research it's not like it's not like um
I'm just not going to do this you know I
I there's a book called The Continuum
concept that is so beautifully written
about this psychologist who follows
these tribes and watches how the how
it's done and it's really the basis of
attachment parenting because it's when
the baby's on your body in the field
with you at all times where you can see
and hear what they need they tell you
when they need to go to the bathroom
they tell you when they need to eat they
tell you what they need and you can
address it because they're right there
yeah these children do not grow up
needing up they're not needy they're not
I know there's a misconception a huge
misconception with like you know
attachment parenting positive parenting
that it makes your kids like
needy insecure it's actually the
opposite they feel more secure yeah
that's at least what I found for sure
and the thing about co- slipping another
thing to touch on a lot of people will
have this fear because of what maybe the
media or other things are telling you
that like it's unsafe or do whatever
doctors but a lot of times it's not
really showing the balance of both sides
like hey look the times when there is
something that's unsafe is is generally
when a mom is either drinking or on
medication and so or anyone in the bed
like so no one in theed bed should be on
medication like that information if you
are not on medication altering your
state like you are so aware even though
you said even though like you said you
are you are asleep you sleep so well but
there's something deep in you that is so
hyper aware you would never that will
never go away as a mother yeah it would
never go away for sure and like you said
that you're so obsessed with your baby
like I just think about little kofax I'm
just obsessed with them when I look at
his little face
I'm just so cute it's so true cuz I when
I talk to someone who doesn't have any
children sometimes they're like oh might
be like a afraid or nervous while
they're holding a baby and I'm like but
once you give birth that all goes away
like it's like this is my baby yeah and
just like that inner Primal and it's so
natural to just want to do the like
keeping your baby close and and follow
your intuition with that well bear and I
still sleep together wow yes so that's
another thing like all the all the stat
I'll be in trouble for saying that but I
don't really care you did elimination
communication that's all oh that's
amazing yeah there's there's no I've
never had a need I've never had a need
to raise my I mean there was one time I
was in the pool and something little
dangerous happened and I said I grab
Bear's little arm and I just said you
may not do
that and he went Mommy why are you
yelling at me I said baby I'm not
yelling he goes but you're so serious I
said I am serious this is serious we're
in a pool and you may not do that yeah
he goes okay
yeah and that was our communication yeah
because it's so true that he's used to
your respectful way of speaking to him
so if there was something super serious
you're still being respectful you're
just being serious he's like who this
serious but if that's how you're always
talking then it's like a lot of times
you have the whole why do I have to yell
at them 10 times they still don't listen
to me that's how you're always talking
to them they're just going to be like
whatever yeah I never yell at him and I
say sorry a lot I do too so if I you
know if I am feeling stressed because
you know for example if bear comes home
from school and I'm trying to cook
dinner get help him with his homework
the dogs are going crazy and I've got
work calls coming in or any variation on
that
above you know which can be any given
day if I haven't slept well cuz I ate
crap the night before or whatever yeah
right or I'm having my period Then I
might be a little bit more prickly now
I'm still not yelling yeah I'm just
simply not as available and I am really
I don't I'm sensitive so I don't like a
lot going on at once so if bear is
talking to me I want to listen you
talked about at the beginning your kids
feeling like I listen to them like I
genuinely otherwise it's noise and the
noise freaks me out I'm either with you
or I want you away like it's I can't I
can't have this sort
of chaos so if Bear's talking to me and
I'm trying to get the dinner ready I
can't I'm sometimes not equipped to do
both sometimes I'm like I can't dinner's
never going to get ready so I'll just
say there I'm so sorry mommy's not able
to do both things right now at the same
time can we can you write down all the
stories you want to tell me and I can't
wait to hear them as soon as I'm done
making the dinner yeah and he's like
okay yeah and it works and then he goes
and does his thing he'll play Legos or
he'll work on his school project or
he'll be reading or whatever he's doing
and and I don't put him on the TV I do
not do media and and I can do this thing
and sometimes in the process over the
years he's forgotten there's been times
when he was little more little and he'd
come in and go but mommy and I'd go okay
great I'm going to write down what's
that story about okay bananas great
bananas we're going to write that one
down and all the stories because I just
I really want to be available and
present it's such precious time I don't
want to lose it but I also have to make
dinner yeah so I know that both things
have to happen I want to be available
and present but I have to make dinner so
the choice right and so we make dinner
and then during dinner he tells me all
the stories and then at bath time he
tells me all the stories and then all
the stories get out and um and I think
it's it's really been amazing he
respects me because I respect him I
remember being a kid and being told you
must respect me and me going but you
haven't earned that this is not behavior
that earns respect you're scary you're
mean you're being an awful person right
so you can't demand it you shouldn't
demand you should it should be um a gift
that they give you because of the way
you are with them the next conversation
I want to share is one of my favorites I
think I've ever had with Dr Laura
Markham a clinical psychologist on the
foundational principles for a peaceful
home and raising happy considerate and
responsible kids if you're a parent and
have not listened to this episode yet go
do it right now you will not regret
taking the time for this one here is one
gold nugget of the many in this episode
my particular approach which I call
peaceful parenting is it's all about the
relationship it's all about the
connection with the child right and it's
about coaching the child to be their
best self instead of resorting to
control rewards punishment threats
yelling okay so that's those are the two
big Ideas right we connect and we coach
the child which includes emotion
coaching and it also includes setting up
the environment for the child to thrive
that might
mean bedtime it might mean fewer screens
it might mean l sugar whatever there you
know Maria montauri said don't try to
control the child control the
environment so the child can Thrive
that's part of coaching right and
emotion coaching we can talk more about
and give some examples but emotion
coaching helps kids with their emotions
so those are the first two big ideas but
notice what's missing here no parent who
is has not had any sleep who is you know
disregulated who is upset and who
believes that their child is um going to
be a spoil Brad if they if they
empathize with them that parent cannot
actually offer the child connection that
parent cannot actually coach they're
going to resort to control out of their
own fear that this child's going to be a
brat right so the third big idea in my
Approach peaceful parenting is parents
have to self-regulate that means you
have to take care of yourself it means
you have to work on your issues that get
triggered so that you can show up as the
parent you want to be and be present
with your child right yes I love that so
those are the three ideas so the
question is does that produce a spoil
brat if you think that you will act out
of your fear and when we act out of fear
we go to the lowest place we can come
from when we act out of fear and we're
always sorry later if you if if anyone
listening reflects on their life and
they think those times when my heart is
overflowing with love and I relate to
the people around me from that versus
those times when I'm I'm scared and I'm
notice how I just tightened up like you
could just feel your heart tighten up
you feel your stomach tighten up you
don't respond from fear in a way that
supports anyone else's growth or your
own you don't support connection you res
when we get scared we control that's
what humans do because we're frightened
so if you come from that perspective you
can guarantee that your child will not
be okay you're undermining the
relationship so I think when people say
that the fear they're really expressing
is
if I empathize with my child and they
are allowed to have these big feelings
they will be out of control and they'll
act badly that so I would say to that
parent they're confusing two things
they're confusing the emotions and the
Behavior now all Behavior does come from
emotions but all Emotions Don't Have To
result in Behavior I may be quite angry
at someone but I'm not going to hit them
I'm not even going to yell at them I'm
going to look look at what's going on
for me that I'm angry at them maybe
they've trespassed some boundary that's
important to me right and I'm going to
express that in words what we have found
through research is that when you
express something in words you don't
actually have to act it out to the
degree that your child can put into
words how angry they are at their little
brother they don't have to hit the
little brother right right so our job as
parents is to say to our kids you can be
as mad as you want too at your brother
you can be as mad as you feel you tell
me about it I hear you oh and he wrecked
your you got that trophy for your sports
and he wrecked your trophy and you told
him not to play with that no wonder
you're mad of course sweetheart right it
sounds like you have something really
important to tell your brother right
I'll help come with me I'll help I'll be
with you while you tell your brother
right and you're also making sure he's
not going to scream at his two-year-old
brother and you know you're you're
protecting both kids but also teaching
them to advocate for them eles right but
notice you're not letting him go smash
his little brother right right even
verbally right so I think that when
parents say gentle parenting produces a
spoiled
brat maybe they've seen someone who says
they're doing gentle parenting who
doesn't set limits that's entirely
possible or maybe it's just Their Fear
talking that they think that a child
who's allowed to have feel their
feelings when they when you acknowledge
feelings that somehow that is bad um I
think humans always have feelings and
feelings are fine and they are part of
our experience of being human and we can
express those and the more our feelings
are acknowledged the less we will
Express those feelings in ways that are
harmful to other people and the more
that we're modeled the behavior and
emotions self-regulated emotions from
our parents then I think also the easier
it becomes as we become adults maybe to
not be super triggered or extra
sensitive like you still have your
feelings but maybe to not such a high
degree where like little things can s
can hypert trigger you because the way
that your parents responded was little
things didn't trigger them no question
my conversation with Heather MC an
international speaker and founder of the
Mind change method on the power of the
subconscious mind is filled with
life-changing information she shares
tools to rewire your brain and heal from
the root cause of trauma I personally
have found immense benefit from this in
many different facets of my life take a
listen to this clip that is really
Illuminating on where our triggers come
from can you believe we are just a
couple months away from the holidays if
you're like me and you love clean Beauty
I've got something special for you as
fall arrives it's a great time for
holiday shopping and right now OA is
offering two Limited Edition holiday
sets oia is a clean vegan cruelty-free
seaweed based Skin and Body Care brand
that I've been obsessed with for years
and I always love to gift their products
to my friends and family because of how
luxurious they are and these sets
already come in a beautiful box for
gifting the andaria body Duo features
limited edition full-size body care for
firming hydration and a full body glow
the body butter is anti-aging and
hydrating and I'm obsessed with the body
oil that leaves my skin radiant and
glowing together these are valued at
$108 but is right now 33% off for $72
the bestsellers minis collection is a
limited edition six-piece set of face
and body bestsellers all wrapped up for
the holidays including the ocean
cleanser hyaluronic CA serum atmospheric
protection cream salts of the Earth body
scrub undaria algae body oil and the
anti-aging body balm literally all of my
favorite oia products which is valued at
$110 and right now is 29% off for $78 to
get these limited edition Duo sets with
10% off your order stacked on top of
this promotion just enter the code Ellen
gift 10 at checkout let me tell you if
an experience happens you are using all
of your senses to store that information
but each individual human does it maybe
more primarily in one of these six ways
kind of like if you're an auditory
learner or a visual learner right and
that doesn't mean you just are that
there you don't learn any other way it's
just your primary way your brain's
favorite way of doing it yeah so we
utilize that too when we're working with
people so I will ask people like if
you've got an issue and the first and
best question is well how do I know this
is happening now with the how do I know
we don't want to be like judgy with
ourselves or anything it's like okay is
it a feeling in my body is it a memory
in the fact that see memory feeling is
memory but we think memories generally
are visual constructs but feelings are
memories too sounds are memories all of
these different things but we need to
find out how I'm doing it so if I have
something let's say I'm in a
conversation with someone and I feel
that triggered feeling and I realize
something comes up in me so what I will
do at that moment is I will go okay I
feel that I'll acknowledge it in myself
right I feel that I hear you I notice
and that helps my body so much even if I
just cognitively I'm like okay I hear
you I got I'm getting the message
something's up here there's information
here and that's the way I look at it oh
information just happened Ellen didn't
do anything to even if you did even if
you were like a emotionally immature you
know like you don't have awareness and
you said a really jerky thing yeah still
the way I perceive that is mine MH right
if I if I could if universally we could
say that was kind of a jerky thing to
say I could say in my mind Ellen is a
jerk or I can go how interesting Ellen
said a jerky
thing or at least that's the way I
perceived it I wonder what's going on
with Ellen if I just know that it's not
me or what if it maybe is me I want to
check that first so I'll go okay wait a
minute wait a minute a minute or maybe I
won't do that like that I'll be like I
will sort of become internal for a
second like oh I'm aware that something
is happening inside of me and I'm going
to regulate me so what I feel like that
any of that let's say it's a physical
I'm going to use the word
disregulation so disre how do I know
there's a
disregulation either I'm put back in a
situation so some people call those
flashbacks that's a disregulation cuz
I'm here now I'm not there but all of a
sudden my head's there and sometimes my
body can be there too disregulation
we've got that's not shouldn't I should
be here not there but it's happening so
I'm not going to judge it I'm just going
to become aware of it or let's say I
have a feeling in my body I all of a
sudden feel like that heart racy feeling
or feel sick to my stomach or I feel
like I want to move away from you all of
these are feelings inside my body that
are there for a good reason so that's my
first and foremost thing that I say I'm
feeling something it's for a good reason
it may not not be something I want to
keep doing but it's good I have a good
reason for doing it at least the way my
mind feels about it so if I have the
moment to do it then I might not like I
may be in a conversation or talking with
my boss and now's not the time for me to
check out and do all this internal work
I will shelf it in the sense that okay
I'm aware that something happened I am
going to check in with this later when I
have the space the safety and the time
and the space to do this so I'm going to
just put it over here but I'm not I'm
not avoiding I'm not judging I'm not
saying there's anything wrong with this
I'm I'm acknowledging it and I'm saying
and making a commitment that I'm going
to get to it later okay so then if I
when I'm home and when I'm in my space
that I can do this then I'll go and sort
of unpack this okay what was really
happening she said this and I felt this
how do I know well I felt this feeling
inside of me and and I'll sometimes ask
myself the question okay well when else
have I felt this feeling and when I say
when else have I felt this feeling I'm
looking for probably the proof that came
way before this conversation to say oh I
felt this before this isn't new Ellen
just triggered something listen if you
can trigger something in me that means
there's something
there I always use this same example and
I know it's silly but I say if you were
to say to me you know you're a purple
alien I'd be
like no you're purple alien gosh I can't
believe you purple aliens I'd be like
are you okay you're like I'm not a
purple okay because listen I know like
I'm not a purple alien it didn't happen
not you cannot convince me otherwise I'm
sorry I love you but
no I would immediately go are you like
are you okay are you being serious like
what's happening right now I would be
very confused because that doesn't that
doesn't resonate with me at
allh now if you say Heather you are so
needy I'd be
like cuz I'd be like oh that resonates
like I'm so afraid that you would think
that about me but that's mine is it true
that I'm needy I don't know is it I got
to check in with myself where is that
coming from why does that hurt me so bad
why does that scare me so much that you
would say that about me my next
conversation on the problem with
wokeness and the breakdown of identity
politics featuring Africa Brooke is
compelling and thought-provoking Africa
is a writer International speaker and
consultant whose work focuses on
tackling self-sabotage and
self-censorship her thoughts Inspire and
impress upon many here's a slice of what
she has to say I had started to sort of
express my frustration in terms of what
was happening culturally just this sort
of
suffocating environment everywhere you
went where you're supposed to pick aside
where you're you're either with us or
you're against us where certain
questions are just not allowed um but no
one ever tells you who who's making
these decisions it's almost like a
social agreement that you've just opted
into um almost like when you visit a
website and then you realize oh
they took my email and I didn't they
didn't even ask
me and then you just start getting
marketing materials it's kind of that's
kind of like how it felt you know um
mantras that I was just supposed to take
on and ideas that were not supposed to
be questioned and even as I say this I'm
sure someone listening just for me just
saying those pretty vague things for Now
you kind of think yeah you you you get
what I'm talking about because of how
intense all of this stuff is but I think
to really um to really kind of give a
more clearer answer I think it's worth
defining woke and wokeness right because
I think there are differences so I I was
going to yes I was going to ask you that
totally right because I I think I think
Ellen sometimes when these conversations
happen everyone has different ideas of
what certain words mean and these are
quite loaded terms especially now um so
I always find it so useful when there
are just clear definitions and if you
were to ask someone else they might say
something different but this is the way
that I was coming at it from so the
origins of the word woke originally it's
a term that started from the US Black
America particularly and it's a very
important and meaningful term for black
people in the US and now it's sort of
spread into the Anglo spere but by
definition it was the state of being
aware so being aware of things like
racism and just inequality in general
and you know again a very important and
useful term especially at that time in
the 60s and the 70s ' 80s even to the90s
but like with most things that start
with a good intention somewhere along
the line they do get co-opted by
people sometimes even well-intentioned
people that end up taking things way too
far right and now wokeness itself in the
present day
20221 it's become more so of an ideology
and within that ideology you have the
extremes of identity politics where you
have hierarchy hierarchies that are
based on identity markers that for
example if you are white you can't have
a say on Race um which I just think is
ridiculous we're all racialized
people and you know if we want to find a
way to bring Unity we need to be able to
to talk and we need to be able to have
the uncomfortable conversations but you
know there are these hierarchies that
you can't even question um you have
things like performative activism where
people think you know just a six slide
infographic is going to change the world
well um sorry to tell you that I I don't
think that's how that's how it works and
you get to doxs people online if you
don't agree with them you get to shame
people in the comment sections or in
Twitter threads um where binary thinking
is encouraged again that Pro or anti
black or white with us or against us
there's just no regard for nuance um and
also it it always looks like a
competition to outw the other person so
because of that environment where
wokeness in the present day has become
like a religion like an ideology and
some really wonderful thinkers from all
sides of the political Spectrum speak
about this very very well I think it's
just worth looking into the sort of
parallels that people um are laying out
to really understand this pretty new
phenomenon if you will um but what that
does is that it creates an environment
where people are just terrified it
creates an environment where people end
up you know just feeling that it's much
safer to self censor because they've
seen what happens to others when they
ask questions they've seen what happens
when you point out a contradiction
they've seen what happens when you're
not you know equipped with all of the
latest and everchanging new terminology
and you say something that maybe other
people consider outdated and before you
know it maybe you've lost your job maybe
you're being publicly shamed you're
being misrepresented it's a very hostile
en environment and as we were saying
because a lot of it is taking place
digitally it's really hard to control
there's no there's no Center there's no
um goal in
mind
so all of that taken into account even
as a black
person
which by you know by the tenants of this
ideology I am somewhere up high on the
hierarchy regardless and it doesn't
matter matter whether my character is
good it doesn't matter what my values
actually are what I actually stand for
is just about the color of my skin it's
just that you're black it's because
you're black therefore that's it that's
it right and slight it's it's not even a
tangent actually it's really important
for this something else that I know is
that my letter has been able to reach so
many people as in they've been able to
receive my words and I haven't received
any push back for my letter it's because
I'm black that people are willing to
listen right someone else could have
said and people have very similar things
just looking at it very objectively but
because we're in a time where people
have decided that actually you're black
so you get to say this but I'm not
saying the things that I should be
saying right I'm saying things that
actually contradict a lot of these
things so we kind of causes a lot of
cognitive dissonance which just shows
you the design of all of this right the
insecurities of our own physical
uniqueness holds us back to our full
potential as human beings some spend
hours a day trying to fix what they
consider to be flaws or frequently
examine their appearance in the mirror
and constantly compare their appearance
with that of others but your beauty is
already within you our mind's perception
is a building block to our Outlook in
life body dysmorphia is often
exasperated through today's societal
Norms of cosmetic and plastic surgery
and even face filters that we now all
see all over social media in this next
episode Sophia esparanza and I unpack
this topic while she shares her own body
dysmorphia story take a listen to this
clip we hyperfixate on things but we're
not we're not really tackling the true
issues and maybe they're not internal
for everybody maybe something is
externally driven but I think a lot of
our problems start here so we have to go
here in order to to begin to even
understand them and then to fix them um
with with my breast implants I started
that I mean that that insecurity began
when I was really really young I've
always been really thin and got made fun
of for that growing up sometimes out of
a place of just mockery from people and
but sometimes for worry actually like
you know sincere concern for my health
because I was thinner than most people
in my family and that made me super um
in tune with the fact that I was just
really thin and and people were alarmed
by it so when I became like 13 years old
kind of everyone hit puberty and I shot
up this way but not really out this way
and so um I had people make fun of my
flat chest and you know just flat
appearance overall and so I couldn't
wait until I was going to grow boobs and
then it was 16 and then it was 17 and I
was couldn't still wait till I was going
to grow boobs and and um yeah I just
from outside in influences like music
and the media and this idea of beauty
and also people around me at the time
who I was surrounding myself by people's
moms even I let that all seep in but
essentially made my own decision to get
breast implants at in my teens which
actually wasn't even legal to do what I
did I had to sign like a waiver because
I got silicone and as soon as I got them
I went from an A cup to a dcup overnight
and cried as soon as I woke up from um
surgery and looked in the mirror I had
to hold it in a little bit um until I
was by myself and I remember just
looking at myself and crying and was
that was that a positive like happy cry
or a sad cry what was what was the
emotion I couldn't recognize myself I
you you spend so much time looking at
yourself for so long and knowing your
body and I realized that the the the
person that I was looking at on the you
know other side of the reflection just
wasn't me and also represented a version
of myself that was fleeting you know
something that I wanted to be sometimes
and I didn't realize that when I wanted
to the surgery that was going to be me
all the time and not having the choice
to move from that form to this one I was
restricted and so um immediately
realized I couldn't breathe as well my
my capacity just was shortened um and uh
or decreased and I had Rippling
immediately as soon as I took off my
bandages I have what you call a double
bubble which is where the implant goes
beneath your natural fold so you
essentially have two folds and this one
is Rock Solid because you have an
implant no fat um and then you have
yours so it can look pretty bizarre and
there you go just added another layer of
insecurity I was like well they only
look good from this angle and you know
or whatever and um this angle I don't
want anyone to see so just another layer
of insecurity right and I knew
immediately I wanted to get them out but
um I kept them in for for a while and it
did it took me until I guess about 3
years ago to get what I thought was
going to be my full explant and get them
out completely but the doctor said they
my skin had been stretched out for so
long that it was a better idea to put a
really small implant in allow my skin to
shrink back while he revises the fold
essentially to like bring my fold back
up to where it was heal and then just
take them out when I'm ready after that
after a year so so that's where I'm at
and um I had coid or I got sick I had a
viral infection I don't know what we can
say on here but um I had it and so it
delayed my surgery a little bit so next
month I'll be if everything goes to plan
I'll be getting them out
completely wow so it's fascinating that
the moment you saw the way you looked
after your implants that you immediately
had this feeling of sadness or regret or
or maybe just a lot of emotions just
knowing all that you were thinking that
hey if I get these implants then I'll be
happy then I'll feel secure and
confident and then just realizing that
that wasn't the answer that's really
that's really fascinating because I
think a lot of women do struggle with um
feeling confident with their breasts and
I think it's helpful for people to hear
stories like this you know it isn't
always going to just fix the solu fix
fix your
insecurities right yeah and I think to
um one of the one other thing that it's
taken me this long in life to realize
obviously as I'm becoming more of age to
or already am at the age to have a child
I see them as a vessel for health for my
child you know they have a purpose
Beyond um aesthetic Beyond feeling
confident and feeling sexy and they give
life literally and I'm so grateful to
even have breast at all there are people
who wish you know that that they had an
acup or just nipples at the very you
know least literally women out there and
so I'm so grateful to have them and so
for me this this word might be
extremely
um I guess alarming it might hit people
in a certain way triggering but to me
what I have done to myself since in my
teens whether it be my my breast
implants or you know trying lip
injections to try to fix this lip issue
that I had in order to try to like as
the the doctor said it'll lift your lip
like didn't it made it heavier it was
terrible and I had to dissolve them um
doing all these things to myself I
realized that the word that kept coming
up up to me was I'm mutilating myself
and again that might be a really
triggering word for for people and they
might not resonate with that and I
completely understand that this is the
way that I feel and my body is so sacred
all of ours are and I I don't want to do
any of that again I've done enough of
that to realize that it it um hits me in
a different way now and um I don't want
to cut her open anymore I don't want to
do anything else I just I want to know
who I actually am because I think when I
know we're going to talk about this
probably but like with the introduction
of filters and all of these different
things we really are losing ourselves uh
we're becoming more familiar with a
filtered version of ourselves the next
conversation I want to highlight is on
optimizing your gut health and
microbiome with Dr will Boltz who's
board certified in Internal Medicine and
Gastro enterology and emphasizes a
holistic approach to Healing the gut I
love this nugget on diets that restricts
certain plants and the benefits of
eating a wide variety of whole plant
Foods as the foundation of your dietary
pattern what about someone who's
listening and they're like but Dr b i
you know tried eating this way I used to
eat like you know the plants and vegan
but like I feel so much better eating
all these animal foods and like not
eating vegetables or excluding whole
grains for my diet what do you have to
say to that well I I've taken care of so
many of these people in my clinic you
know this is my work as a gastron
neurologist this is what I've dedicated
my life to and um what I have discovered
time and time again is that if if a
person gets a benefit by restricting
their diet of these Foods I'm talking
about whole plant Foods yeah if a person
gets a benefit many times they don't but
if they do it is
shortlived and what they discover is
that their gut
problems
persist and they get worse like over
time over time and they end up in a
spiral and it's a spiral where they are
progressively restricting restricting
restricting and I just told you the
number one predictor of a healthy gut
microbiome is the diversity yeah so it
makes sense if you're like restricting
these whole variety of whole plant Foods
let's say you have a philosophy that you
shouldn't eat these types of vegetables
like cruciferous vegetables or legumes
or grains and you're very very rarely
eating foods like that then over time
like you're microbes are gonna diminish
and then if you do try to introduce it
then you're like gonna experience even
more problems than you did before well
because your your gut is adapted to the
type of stuff that you're doing right so
um I played uh several Sports in high
school and I would transition from
soccer into basketball season so I'm
playing soccer and I'm an athlete right
and I start and I flip over to
basketball season and I'm winded mhm and
I'm hurting right I'm dragging because
my body was not adapted to the
difference between soccer and basketball
with exercise your body adapts to what
you're doing right if you work out your
legs but you don't work out your chest
you're going to get some big muscular
legs but you should not expect to have a
big muscular chest because you're you're
not working on that totally right same
is true for our gut If you eliminate
legumes don't call me up and say hey Dr
b i eliminated legumes for six months
and now it's hard for me to reintroduce
them what the heck like there's a reason
why this happens the reason why it
happens is that your gut and its um
ability is directly correlated to the
diet that you are currently
eating and so when you eliminate
something from your diet you are
disabling your gut you are reducing the
ability of your gut to handle that
specific food and it gets worse and
worse and worse as time goes on and at
the moment that you decide to intervene
you're going to face challenges yeah
yeah that's so fascinating it's
something that you don't really hear
there's all this talk about like
elimination diets like take out this
take out this and this is better if you
do this your your gut health will be
better for this and there's not much
talk about the importance of the the
diversity of plants in your diet right
no we we really want that diversity of
plants and you know just to kind of
hammer this just a little bit more Ellen
a few things we I I mentioned before
that like I want people not to be
running away from stuff I want people to
be running towards food that brings them
Joy right and so but there's an issue
which is that people are just flat out
not consuming fiber rich foods mhm if
you look the average American in the
United
States uh is consuming about 17 grams of
fiber per day all right and that's
because only 10% of their calories come
from plants MH and 60% of their calories
come from Ultra processed foods
typically where we you asked about this
before we extract the
fiber and we add in chemicals as
preservatives right or colorant or
whatever it may be and isolated Foods
right and then we and then you know we
then like package it up and it like sits
on the shelf for 12 months and it's the
exact same food on the day that you
packaged it like it has not degraded or
you know decomposed in any way that's
actually disturbing food is meant to be
decomposed food has a life cycle like
our ability to create something that
ever has a life cycle is means that it's
not really alive anymore mhm um so
anyway that's 60% of the average
American's diet 30% of our calories come
from animal products you can consume all
the animal products that you want the
average American right now uh eats their
body weight plus the body weight of a
5-year-old child in animal products on a
yearly basis wow so the average intake
of animal products is uh meat by the way
not including Dairy not including dairy
or eggs so um and I believe not
including fish but the average American
is consuming 2 120 lb of meat and the
average American only weighs 170 lb mhm
so 170 lb their body weight plus a 50 lb
child uh that's how much meat they're
eating now 220 lb of uh meat well I can
tell you how many grams of fiber there
are in 220 pounds of
meat zero mhm there's not even one you
get zero gram of fiber in meat mhm so
there are things about meat that concern
me about their effect on the gut
microbiome but one of the biggest issues
is that it's devoid of fiber MH and so
we have constructed a diet that only has
10% of our diet that actually produces
the fiber that our gut microbes need to
thrive and here we sit and the average
American is getting about 17 gr of fiber
per day the recommended amount of fiber
for a woman is 25 gr of fiber the
recommended amount of fiber for a man is
38 grams of fiber and so here we are and
95% of
Americans yeah are not even getting the
minimum recommended recommended amount
of fiber MH if you are listening to this
right now and you are saying okay so
what do I do about it Dr B it is so
straightforward and simple because once
again I told you I don't count grams of
fiber mhm I count
plants I don't count
calories I count plants I don't count
macros I count plants count your plants
I want people to be inspired to make
diversity of plants the centerpiece of
their dietary choices you're in the
supermarket you're trying to figure out
what you're going to pick up you hear Dr
B from your podcast come through their
air waves and say diversity of plants
yeah yeah you are cooking chili you're
in the
kitchen you could keep it super simple
but you know what why not have five or
six types of beans in there Dr B
diversity of plants you are sitting down
at the dinner table and there is a wide
array of plants at that table and you
get to choose which ones you like but Dr
B says diversity of plants M and so it's
a way in which you can make it your own
and if you do this and you focus on this
you make this an important part of your
dietary
approach these concerns about inadequate
fiber consumption they will go away
because you will be cranking up the
plants in your diet you will be moving
towards a plant predominant diet M
possibly you will become like you and I
plant exclusive yeah and this will
transform your health right transform
your life bring you great joy you don't
have have to make compromises it can be
in abundance you can eat until you're
full and then you emerge from this
delicious plate and you say I feel great
and alive and that's what I want for
every single person yeah totally cancel
culture is a topic I knew I wanted to
tackle since the creation of this
podcast in this episode my friend FY
Rock Christina shares her experience
being criticized and called out in the
public eye multiple times over the
course of her career with her and her
previous partner cash we un dissect and
reflect on the rise of callout culture
its benefits versus consequences for our
society and how we can move forward we
also get into the importance of
listening to dissenting opinions to your
own and not assuming ill intent in
others take a listen I think that people
have forgotten the humanity in others
especially online totally right so I
love love what you're saying you know
like this essence of bringing love to
the table even if you don't have
something in common with somebody and
talking it out and just listen
listening understanding where they're
coming from you don't have to believe
the same things but like I can love you
and disagree and I can listen it's like
this is how you bring love to the table
it's a skill it it's a skill to practice
but we're in a society right now where
it's like you can only follow people
that have similar like God forbid I
follow somebody on Instagram who's not
vegan I've actually had people message
me and say I can't believe you follow
this person don't you see what they just
did unfollow them immediately I get that
all the time all the time I I just I
don't even pay attention to it anymore
because I'm I don't like that because I
I don't want to live in an echo chamber
I like to hear dissenting opinions on
all different kinds of things because it
helps me to either solidify what I
believe even further and stronger
because I know what the other side is is
what their views are or it helps me to
possibly shift my mind or even if I
don't shift my mind to just see where
they're coming from and try to relate
because I don't think it's helpful to
assign ill intent exactly and that's
something you were talking about if you
want to expand more yeah well and I
definitely like what you're saying as
well we it's so easy to get trapped into
curating your social media platform to
all of your
likes um and I don't mean likes as in
what you're liking pictures but your
interest because soon as there's
opposition in your Viewpoint there's
like there's a breach 100% and you're
uncomfortable now because it doesn't
follow the the flow of your timeline and
it's like okay
report unfollow block don't want to see
that and what that does is reinforce
beliefs that this is the right way
without having a conversation with the
other side or seeing what the other side
is doing to like you said to get the
Common Ground if we have tunnel vision
in only one way we're so far from the
middle ground that we're unaware what
middle ground is and I think social
media allows us to be in this false
world and forgetting like yeah it's okay
to exist with someone who doesn't have
the same views as you but if you have a
peaceful conversation a conversation
with compassion to understand and hear
them out we actually can grow through
this and have maturity and development
um and that's something that's missing a
lot because it's uncomfortable but
that's where the growth is like that's
really where the growth is absolutely
and you know there sure there's going to
be some people who do have an ill intent
but to assign everyone as to have ill
intentions if you disagree with them I
think is a huge disservice to like our
mental growth yeah and understanding
because I think Mass majority do not
have ill intent yeah in what they're
what they believe one thing that I was
always taught is to try to give try to
observe positive intentions before I
jump to the conclusion of it being ill
intentions and so I was taught that okay
if this happens like if someone comes in
one day and they're frustrated and then
they just happen to outlash something at
me I need to ask myself maybe they're
having a bad day maybe it's not me but
if this becomes a repeated behavior and
this is me having positive intentions
like saying like there's outside factors
that could be affecting them that's
causing them to like lash out at me but
if this becomes a repeated Behavior now
you have a historical record of like hey
you need to address this the way you're
like presenting yourself online with
social media or in the workplace or in
your
relationship is it creates this
opportunity for positive feedback or
specific feedback where people can just
say and that's kind of like something we
did in our relationship where it's like
I appreciate you for taking the time out
and seeing something that I was unaware
of because when we get in these like
ruts of frustration or Misery we don't
really see it someone has to point it
out to us um 100% And A lot of people in
life really need that person in their
life because if no one points it out
you're just in this cycle you're in this
cycle and you you can see that that it's
apparent in a lot of people's Liv
because the way how social media is so
divisive piggy backing off of that this
next episode with my husband resonated
with a lot of people it was highly
requested for me to have my wonderful
husband on the podcast whom I admire his
character so much and in this clip
Andrew shares his thoughts on making
assumptions about people how people come
to form their perspectives and putting
others in boxes in this episode we also
answer some of your questions about our
relationship what it's like raising five
children together how we handle
criticism and keeping the spark alive
after 20 years doing life together I
love this man so much we talk a lot
about this about not putting people in
boxes and understanding listening from
all different perspectives because the
funniest part about that to me was that
people would say oh Andrew follows Trump
and he follows I don't know a couple
other right people politically but then
they also didn't look that like you also
follow Joe Biden and you also follow
like who are the other ones you're so
much more to politics than I am but
whoever's the president oh Bernie
Sanders Bernie sand you follow you
follow like all the different all the
different politically things Dan kensaw
and all this stuff but people saw that
you followed a couple different people
that they really don't like and they
said it must you must be this this this
this what are your thoughts I don't
really care what other people think
about me to be honest yeah you are very
good I think it's silly when you that
people would make such big assumptions
based off following someone on Twitter
or Instagram or Facebook or whatever it
is because I just I like I like having
disagreements with people like I don't
mind having political discourse or
having different opinions on things it
doesn't trigger me where some people for
whatever reason uh it's more like how
could someone think something else than
me like they must be this type of person
and that's just not me so it's easy for
me to follow different people on social
media that I agree with and disagree
with and it doesn't it's not not
triggering for me to see someone post
something that I disagree with I'm like
oh that's interesting like it's not like
it ruins my day to see someone even if I
think it's like something that could be
possibly harmful like I understand that
people come from all different ways of
life and have so many different
upbringings that we kind of form our
opinions about
things uh politically or just what our
priorities are in life based off you
know a lot of what you know our
childhood and things that may have may
may or may not have happened to us or
our parents or the religion we grew up
in and to understand that people get to
a certain point because of the
experiences they have it helps you
understand understand them a little bit
better and uh when you put people in
boxes and just say oh this person voted
for this person or follows this person
it kind of takes away their humanity and
it kind of just like it's like that
that's just not the kind of it's not
going to be very fruitful for our
country or for for people in general if
that we just treat people like that uh
but thankfully for me it doesn't bother
me when when people make statements like
that about me I have certain values
certain things that are very important
to me uh that I'm passionate about
because of what I want what's best for
my kids or I was exposed to something
and or was not exposed to something um I
found it I don't have the exact survey
but there was a survey that someone had
shared about about uh political
affiliation and then their thoughts on
Co and people were asked how serious uh
they thought Co was or how what the
death rate was or how many people get
Hospital's do percent chance to be
hospitalized and people that thought the
facts were one way like say you thought
that Co was 50% of people that got it
were were hospitalized and 20% of people
died those people tended to be more
fearful of Co rightfully so and were
more likely to be concerned about what
other health choices people were making
with vaccines and masks whereas people
that felt like Co was not as serious
were less likely to to want to wear
masks or be worried about someone else
getting a vaccine and understanding like
you're going to have your opinions based
off what you believe is true and
sometimes are we what's true just
because of our opinions and sometimes we
believe it because of fact I tend to be
more fact oriented and I'm not as
empathetic and I don't have as I'm not
more feeling feeling based so I make my
decisions more more cut and dry what do
the facts say but I realize that's not
everybody and understanding that that's
okay that people have different opinions
than me and I'm never going to put
someone down because they disagree with
me because ultimately most people just
believe what they believe because they
think that's what's best for them or
their families or for others we just
maybe disagree on how to get there and
if you can understand that most people
are aren't out to get you except someone
that's on the left or the right and you
think the other way they're not they're
not doing these things because they want
to destroy the world or destroy your
family or attack you personally or a
group of people personally they just
have a different path on making things
better and uh yeah it's unfortunate that
there's videos made about you assuming
you was the one I remember seeing the
one where you have like a trump hat on I
thought that was hilarious superimposed
and then people actually thought it was
a real picture yeah someone yeah so
there's a picture of me pregnant that I
had posted but then someone superimposed
a trump hat on top of my head like a
fake picture and someone had put that up
in the thumbnail of a video and then
somebody later people later are
commenting yes pictures later surfaced
of Ellen wearing a trump hat like those
aren't even real pictures it was so OB
internet's a funny place I know I find
it funny when people want to put me in a
box or assume something I'm just kind of
laughing off because it's like that's
not who I am and it doesn't trigger me
because I know that's not who I that's
not who I am and so it's you're super
confident yeah I'm confident and and I
know the truth and I know what I believe
and someone on social media can't
possibly know that unless we have a
conversation and they get to know me
well yeah so that's why when somebody
sees a picture like oh Andrew liked this
picture or liked this post and this is a
horrible post it's anti this or that
instead of like jumping to conclusions
that must mean that Andrew is a bigot or
a blah blah blah instead like it would
be so much more engaging and fruitful to
figure out like why would somebody maybe
agree with that post or either go to him
directly or go like look at the other
side there are so many people that only
want to look at one side of the aisle of
anything this isn't just politically but
anything anything of hot debate that's
definitely there's so many topics of hot
debate that aren't just political and
listen truly listen to both sides cuz if
if you think oh I can't even listen to
it that's not admirable to say that I
can't possibly understand why anybody
would think the other way it because it
just shows that you haven't actually
given it much time much effort to really
hear what the other side is so how do
you even know if you're on the side of
truth if you haven't even given equal
attention and time to listening to both
sides yeah you should be able to argue
the other way like that's what I try to
I try to think okay how could I argue
this if I'm pro-life how could I argue
against pro- lifee or if I'm pro-choice
how could I argue against pro-choice
like once you are able to do that it
helps you to understand the other side
like I said earlier like most people are
just doing what they think is right or
morally acceptable or what they think is
going to be the most beneficial to
society and acknowledging like that
they're not coming from a place of evil
wanting to harm and they're coming from
a place of Love most people obviously
there's people that aren't that's not
their goal but just the life experience
thing is such a big factor like I'm
pro-life like I'm not afraid to say that
but the reason I'm I'm that way is
there's so many life experiences that
I've had that I can't be other it's hard
for me to imagine not being that but I
can still understand why someone is on
the other why on the other side and you
know I'm a father I witnessed All My
Children be born I can't imagine doing
anything other than protecting my
children when I was in college I'd had a
biology class we went to a hospital
hospital and there was a 5 gallon bucket
of fetuses that had passed away and I
don't know if they were aborted or if
they were and just miscarriages went up
they were from 12 weeks to 24 weeks and
they weren't treated as human they you
know we weren't allowed to see the the
morg or the adult bodies were even
though this was a biology class but we
were allowed to see the fetuses because
they didn't classify them as human I
guess and they brought in this five
gallon bucket of about 20 of them and we
were able to pick them and hold them and
look at them and I was like these are
humans they're small but they're humans
and that formed my my belief so strongly
right there it was official yeah that I
was pro-life and I wasn't going to
change yeah because that's my experience
but if you've never lived that
experience and you maybe seen the
opposite of someone being raped and
Pregnant and then seen the horror of
having to go through that like I I've
never had that experience so it's not
it's easy it's not easy for me to see
where they're coming from but I can
still like oh that would be hard even
though I haven't lived that experience
uh just understanding that we all get to
our we all get to where we the things we
believe for a reason and for the most
part it's because we just want what's
best for others and what's best for soci
at least that's for me yeah I do I agree
with you I think that most people are
have pure intentions and so to we should
assume pure intentions for all sides of
the aisle of any topic that you're pass
passionate about that helps you to go
into the conversation better to just try
to understand the way someone thinks as
opposed to think jumping to conclusions
that someone who disagrees with me must
be a this this or this like labeling
another debate episode which I loved
monogamy versus polyamory I recently had
on the Pod Amelia and Matt a couple that
practices consensual non- monogamy and I
share an opposing views conversation
with them alongside my husband we are
both passionately Pro monogamy and in
this conversation we get into monogamy
versus polyamory for relationships
children and Society here's a powerful
clip where we go back and forth on what
is the meaning of sex so to me it sounds
like sex is more transactional than it
is like Soul tying because like what are
what are your thoughts on sex is it is
it something that's oh it's it's like
going and playing it's like bowling with
somebody like you go out you go out and
you bowl and then you go back to your
husband you bowl with a friend you know
or is it is it a soul tie is it this
sacred mind mind Body Spirit experience
if it's with someone that you're
lifelong committed to versus someone you
just met a couple days ago or a week ago
or whatever what do you feel like your
sex can be as deep and intimate with
someone you just met versus the person
that you are so ride or die with the
person you're in love with you bend
through thick and thin with like what do
you think about
that well first I feel like it's worth
mentioning like we'll go on maybe let's
say we go on a 100 dates and out of
those 100 dates we're not probably even
as much as kissing the first 70 people
like we're not just out trying to sleep
around and get it where we can it's
Absolut like absolutely intentional and
um yeah of course we want to feel that
connection before we explore in any
intimacy or um yeah you want to feel
safe you want to feel attracted to them
you want the chemistry to align
absolutely and um I do feel that we have
found ways to almost like enhance and
maybe sustain our incredible Connection
in sex life because I mean I mean the
reality for us at least the reality for
me and maybe for you is and for many
women and men I don't know if you guys
have ever heard of the term liance
before it's like new relationship energy
you have yeah the chemistry the
butterflies right that so now there's
studies saying that women usually
experience like a tremendous decrease or
decline in their limerance in the first
two to three years of a monogamous
long-term relationship and for men it's
5 to seven years so yeah we've been able
to still you know have this incredible
partnership have amazing sex have each
other love each other be intimate and
then also you know I've been able to be
honest and say oh you know I met someone
out on the surf or I met a guy and
there's a bit of a Vibe and I might go
grab dinner with him and then maybe a
few weeks later I'm still hanging out
with him and say to Matt I'm kind of
interested in exploring what it could
feel like to have an intimate connection
with him and um no it's not it's not
probably the same level of sex and um
connection but it's still beautiful and
I think I always come back learning
something about myself or about the sit
situation that I can then bring home to
my partnership with Matt and say oh you
know I was thinking about this and this
came to mind and well I really enjoyed
it and it was great and I kind of feel
like I got this like I got it out of me
and maybe I'll do it again or maybe I
won't but if anything I'd say it comes
home I come home appreciating more the
connection we have and the partnership
and the chemistry and um yeah that's why
we don't really often ever do sleepovers
because usually we just love sleeping
with each other so much and so we feel
we feel that same level of connection
and or maybe not the same but we feel a
version of that level of connection and
deep like intimacy with one another and
and we probably we attract different
people as well like you attract a
different kind of male and I guess I
attract a different female and yeah a
lot of the people I connect to a deep
into like tantric and calini and I think
when you have sex with somebody that
understands the calini and the The
Awakening and the evolving through that
and the the slowness and the the way to
to to more be your purest self without
any of the constructs applied to the
identity you become this within
Kundalini and within tantric you become
this pure version and and I think
through the evolution of our
relationship I'm attracting a lot of
women that are wanting that same condal
tantric uh connection so and which is a
beautiful thing I mean those teachings
you can you can really get to know
yourself and get to really connect with
other people as as as we do as well so
so yeah you want to try them in what do
I think sex is yeah what do you think
yeah yeah I view it as more of a a
sacred Bond I mean I my my belief system
is just different like I I believe I
have more Christian beliefs so my belief
is there's one ultimate design for sex
our creator designed us to be with one
person for a reason uh sometimes you may
like question those reasons uh but I
feel like the main reason is to protect
the family to protect the relationship
and to deepen the bond with your partner
and I don't have any experience of being
with someone else so it's like we're
coming out from very different places
like we've only been together obviously
so it's really easy for me to just kind
of see it like well this works great for
us like this seems like a no-brainer you
know I it uh it aligns with my belief
system as well uh but I can see how when
you have different life experiences is
you know serial monogamy sleeping with
multiple partners before you find the
one person you want to marry how it
could be possibly more tempting or more
desirable to want to sleep with other
people or be worried like well I don't
want to be stuck with one person for the
rest of my life because you've had other
experiences and you know there's
different levels of quality yeah what if
they're not as good at sex as the last
person that's something that I got asked
a lot well you're waiting until you're
married what if he's not good at sex
like I got asked that all the time this
next episode on the topic of History
repeating itself critical thinking and
personal responsibility Division and
unity and freedom versus mandates came
at a heightened time of emotions for
everyone during the age of Co in 2021 so
it was a pretty polarizing episode but
nonetheless an interesting conversation
for sure because it included zubie an
independent rap artist public speaker
and creative entrepreneur this man was
incredible to connect with and I so
enjoyed our conversation take a listen
just look at the 20th century let's just
look at the last 100 years right anyone
who can look at the last 100 years and
come to the conclusion that the
government always has the people's best
interest in mind
is naive or stupid like and I I don't
like calling people stupid but you can't
look at the 20th century whether you're
talking about the rise of Hitler and
Nazism to Mao in China to um pinese to
Stalin to Paul pot to all of these
dictators in the Middle East and Africa
Etc Saddam Hussein right how can you
come to the conclusion that the
government governments always have best
people's interest in mind absolute
nonsense right you know you fact
factually that's not an opinion that's
factually incorrect I mean I naively my
whole life thought we're past this we're
past all the horribleness that have
happened in the world I really did I was
like there's no way something like a
holocaust or slavery in like a a more
developed Nation would happen again like
we're totally past all the hardship
people forget that we're still living
through history mhm right people think
that history is over right history is
over Freedom one there's no more
dictators there's no more best I mean
come on North Korea still exists guys um
so it's that it's honestly it's uh it's
complacency and it's it's great that in
the modern West you know it's been such
a long time it's been several decades
since we've really had you know I mean
like a a real severe War whether it's a
World War I or World War II or even
Vietnam sure there have been Wars In Our
Lifetime but not in the way that
Generations before us used to deal with
so it's easy to look at the situation
and think oh we're here now
and things just keep going forward right
I imagine if you went back to
1921 in 1921 people thought that hey
we're so modern we're so sophisticated
we're we're not we're not like these
brutes back in history who were
committing genocide and always going to
war and doing all this nonsense right
like do you think that the Germans back
in 1921 were there like oh yeah like
this is going to happen in the next
couple of course not nobody saw it
coming and it's so important and for
people to understand that we are not
fundamentally different to our ancestors
we are the same people we have not
evolved you don't think we've evolved no
not at all I kind of I tend to think
that like through all the hardship and
the barbaric stuff that has happened
there's like these little moments of
clarity on how to be more loving and
more um kind and then like raising your
children that way and I kind of feel
like over time that's how like Nations
have gotten better and what we fought
for but then we just can't get lazy to
think that it could never happen again
yeah so I I agree with you to an extent
so we are more enlightened than our
ancestors because we can look back at
their errors and mistakes yeah right
that's the value of knowing history
because you can look back at it and you
can oh let's not do that again that was
a bad idea and finally I cannot forget
my conversation with my friend and
nutritionist Simon Hill his health
obsession with nutritional science and
reliable science-based information makes
the information he shares incredibly
reliable in this episode we cover the
biggest nutrition myth by breaking down
today's most popular diets and Trends
here is a fascinating clip with
information that often gets left out of
the nutrition conversation online for
anybody who maybe is skeptical of
research and Science and wants to look
back more at the appeal to Nature type
of look how do you respond to that when
they because you you sort of touch on it
but can you go into a little bit further
about why we don't want to just look at
the appeal to Nature that well our
ancestors ate that way what is what's
the disconnect there well I think we
just have to it just comes back to
realizing like what the goal of our our
ancestors was and what evolution is it's
to get you to an age to procreate
Evolution does not care if you have a
heart attack at 60 Evolution does not
care if you have a heart attack at 70 it
doesn't care if you get cancer at 60 or
70 right so if you're interested in good
health later in life we have to look
Beyond speculation of what our ancestors
may or may not have eaten and back to
what I said earlier I don't even think
we can put our finger on like this is
the ancestral diet you can get some
general themes but there's there's no
way of of doing that so you know I think
you can you can look at that and be
interested in it but if your goal is to
increase the number of years that you
live in good health which is essentially
increasing your health span you're
trying to shrink the number of years
where you're affected by disease then
you have to look to the science that is
studying people over time and looking at
biomarkers that predict longevity right
because we have different goals to our
ancestors yes we're not just here to
survive we have so many food um options
available to us that our ancestors
didn't and so we're in this privileged
position of saying okay we don't have to
just go out and eat calories to survive
and eat whatever we can get our hands on
we can actually
look at the science that we have and
make a more calculated decision and
increase our chance of getting to
6065 without developing cancer without
having a heart attack without having a
stroke and so hopefully to our 80s and
90s yeah exactly and the other thing to
consider here is the types of foods that
our ancestors were eating and whether
they are the same as the types of foods
that people who are adopting different
variations of these ancestral diets are
eating today specifically Ty Al meat so
there's a really interesting paper by
Lauren cordain who is kind of like the
father or one of the fathers of the
paleo diet and he wanted to look at what
are the the typical cholesterol levels
in hunter gatherer tribes anyone can go
out and look at this and there's a
beautiful graph in there and with the
data that's available to us looking at
different Hunter gather of tribes we
know that their cholesterol levels are
not high now you might think well how
can that be if they're eating a lot of
animal foods that are rich in saturated
fats What's Happening Here well there's
good kind of archaeological evidence
that suggests the types of meats that
our ancestors were eating were probably
a lot leaner than the types of meats
today so leaner than than beef and lamb
you know our ancestors would have been
eating woolly mammoth and Antelope and
and you know venison type of type of
meat so um you know that's that's the
other thing to kind of consider here
when we're thinking about like eating
like our ancestors are we truly eating
like them or are we kind of just eating
the foods that we want to eat today and
making ourselves feel good by you know
telling ourselves that that's the same
foods that they ate a long time ago um
so that's the kind of you know that's
the way that that I think about that I
think a lot of people who might be
listening maybe your audience but
definitely my audience might be younger
and so they're they may they might not
be thinking that far down the road and
so it's easy to just go to this oh yeah
this makes sense this you know nature
this is how our ancestors ate not
realizing that there are certain foods
that definitely prevent our biggest
killer so when you take that evidence
into consideration it kind of goes
against that personal bias that you
would have and I think maybe we should
first cut like round out the topic of
butter it's very becoming very popular
now that oh we're getting back to the
way that our great-grandparents lived on
a farm and they milk their own cow and
then we make our own butter and it's so
healthy for us why is it not so healthy
for us the big two reasons are a PO B so
it's going to increase apop we got to
remember heart disease is the number
one cause of death globally it's the
most likely reason that any of the
listeners are going to die right so you
should take that pretty seriously if
there's a bio Market you're going to be
most interested in it's a PO B um I also
mentioned that saturated fat so butter
is very rich in saturated fats and
particular the saturated fats that
increase hepatic fat so increase that
fat that's building up in the liver it's
building up in the pancreas it leads to
insulin resistance so from a metabolic
Health it's going to be damaging there
compared to eating foods that are rich
in in unsaturated fats whether that's
monounsaturated fats or polyunsaturated
fats um so you know I think that the the
reason that this is trendy is because
people see it as kind of natural
ancestral but they're not
appreciating that they can feel good
today and still be increasing their risk
of disease in decades to come because
these things bubble away under the
surface
ultimately it comes back to where we
started this conversation is that the
the science is very clear that there is
a theme that is consistent with
long-term good long-term health and that
is a diet that is low in saturated fats
it's rich in polyunsaturated fats low
and Ultra processed foods this is not
debated in nutrition in the academic
science world it's only debated online
is it is absolutely the consensus
position with regards to how do we get
people to feel really good today and
feel better long term what an incredible
first season of this podcast I am
grateful for all of you who have been
joining along this ride links to all the
episodes and social media accounts to
the guests in this episode are in the
show notes stay tuned for next season I
cannot wait for what's in store
[Music]
look